a coders and welcome back to another
view Jas tutorial where I'm going to
show you how to build a markdown
previewer app so just to kind of show
you what we're building on the left here
we have a text area where we can type
our markdown and if you're not familiar
with markdown basically it's a hyper
text language where it compiles down to
HTML and in markdown you can do a bunch
of different stuff such as create titles
so this is going to make an h3 title I
do one of them is going to make an h1
title and on the right this is kind of
the HTML that the markdown is going to
be rendered into after it compiles
just show some of them we can do you
know of course titles we can do bullet
points so I'll say one two three we can
do this random paragraph
text
copy and paste that a bunch
of course we could do unordered lists
here so one two three
demonstrate links
we could do something like this so I'll
say Google comm and that's gonna be a
hyperlink tool
[Music]
google.com fact I think I mixed that up
let me this
there we go that's the correct way to do
it so you can do links you can do images
I simply
doing something like this and notice
that we don't have an image here so let
me just go to like Google Images and say
view image
go to images and I'm going to go here
and just copy this image URL so copy
images rest and then instead I'm going
to paste this
a view so that's just kind of showing
off like what we're building we're not
going to use any external markdown
packages that exist or else this
tutorial will probably be like five
minutes we're going to try to create our
own markdown directive and we're going
to use regex to kind of PARs this text
and re-render HTML on the right over
here so this is a good tutorial to kind
of practice writing directives practice
writing view components that interact
with each other etc so let's get started
building out this preview I went ahead
and just created a new project using
view CLI origin 3 and using the
generated code let's just go ahead and
alter some stuff to make this work so
inside app view I'm going to just remove
our hello world stuff and we can just go
ahead and get started
one thing I will note that I already did
is inside our index.html I went ahead
and just brought in a Google web font in
a bootstrap CSS file so that we can use
the CSS grid to kind of lay out our
application so nothing nothing too crazy
going on in here and then also what I'm
gonna do before we start going too much
further is inside our assets folder I'm
going to add a style that CSS file and
I'm going to import that in our main J's
file so I'm gonna say import dot assets
style that CSS just so that we can kind
of declare some top-level assets if we
need them
so with that being said let's start by
going into app dot view
and in order to achieve what we saw with
what we're going to build we need to
kind of start laying out some Styles so
the first thing I'm going to lay out is
I'm going to say a class is equal to
container which is a bootstrap class and
that basically will just make sure that
everything is wrapped and kind of
centered on the page
once we have a container class lined out
we can then do class of row
and inside your rose that's where you
can declare your columns so on the first
row we're just going to make this a
class of column so make sure it takes up
all the 12 grid locations and we're
going to give this an h1 of markdown
preview and if I save this we should see
markdown preview pop up at the top one
thing we also have in bootstrap is a
text align so I'm going to say text
Center just to make sure that is aligned
in the center
awesome so that is our first row for our
second row we want to split that into
two columns so as I call em d6
inside this each tag I'm going to say
markdown and instead of h1 I'm gonna do
h4 and then we're gonna have another
column right next to that so this is our
left column this is a right column and
this is going to say preview
and these are going to be text-align to
left so these look pretty good of course
we can do a little bit of style changes
to make this you know have some margin
at the top have this have some MT and -
for for margin at the top mm-hmm
nothing too crazy but before we start
diving into laying out the text area in
the preview section let's go back to
that style dot CSS and just give the
page a little bit more aesthetically
pleasing styles so one I'm going to just
copy and paste in is a linear gradient
for the background and that is basically
going to make it look a little bit nicer
for background I don't know if that's a
not a UX expert but it looks pretty nice
I guess
and I'm just gonna go ahead and just
give like a hard-coded height to this
just so that doesn't keep repeating and
inside the body what I'm also going to
do is I'm going to include that font
family called libri Franklin which is
granted from that Google web font that
we've brought in just to make the font
look a little bit nicer
all right and then secondly inside the
style I'm just gonna add a light clasp
which is just going to be used for
making the text white and maybe also
adding some drop shadow to that text so
basically light class is gonna have a
text shadow and it's gonna be white so
in here I could just go to all my H ones
and just give it a class of light and
make those look a little bit nicer cool
so the first thing we want to do is if
you remember in that example I showed on
this left column we had a text area so
let's just go ahead and add a text area
here the user can type in their markdown
that text area let's just go ahead and
declare class info so we can style it
so down at the bottom here I'm gonna say
let's remove all the stuff was we don't
need it time to scope this and I'm going
to do class info and just give it a
height of 400 pixels and a width of a
hundred percent for now
have a text area which again both of
those styles are showing up
hmm and then let's just go ahead and add
a little bit of pasady to the background
just so it's not so write up a white for
the text area I don't want it to be
resizable so resize is none and that'll
get rid of that little resize icon at
the bottom
then additionally let's give it a orange
order
you'd be given like two pixels for that
or something
outline of nun
so then we click on it's not outlined
and I think that should be okay for the
text area so on the right column what we
want to do is declare a div which we're
going to pretty much be putting our mark
down in so I'm going to say div that's
also going to be a class info
I'll just in that dip right there and
say this and we should get
a nice-looking preview area now
and basically what we want to do here is
inside of this div let's just render out
markdown and again we haven't defined
this yet so let's go to our actual
component script area and we're going to
say data that's going to return a object
that has a markdown property
and I'll say that in basically
it's just going to render out whatever
markdown is
next step is we want to kind of bind the
text area to this markdown data property
so what we can do is inside the text
area a directive you can use in view is
called v-model and I'm just going to
pass that markdown so now basically
whatever I type into markdown it's going
to be rendered on the right side so if I
type in like hello world
you
that okay so we're making some good
progress little baby steps now at this
point we haven't really touched our mark
down directives but that's what we're
going to be doing now so if we go back
to our main DJ s
let's go ahead and just pretend that we
have a directive already declare it so
I'm gonna say import markdown from at
slash directive slash markdown so we
assume that there's a file called
markdown there and we want to define
that inside of our view app as a
directive called markdown
and just go ahead and pass down that
markdown object and say that this should
crash because we haven't created it yet
and basically what this is doing is
we're just telling view if you see the
keyword be marked down anywhere just go
ahead and use this markdown object that
we're gonna declare so going back to our
code let's make that folder called
directives and let's make that file
called markdown j/s and then in here
inside this markdown J's file I can just
do export default and object save that
and now at this point we are still
working
and kind of the last piece of that
puzzle is now that we have the ability
to use that markdown directive let's use
the directive so very similar to this V
model which is a directive that's built
in the view we just made a custom
directive which we can declare just by
putting V markdown so now this div the
be marked on directive is going to be
applied to O so for those who don't
really understand what directives are
basically again you bind them to your
Dom elements and they're going to run
some code when stuff happens so one of
the Hooksett a directive provides us is
the bind hook so inside here basically
when the directive is bound to the B
node slash the Dom element it's going to
run and this is basically only going to
run once when the component is kind of
like mounted so if you notice here it
printed out this info div now that we
have this element we can do things to
the text of the element you kind of
modify it and just to kind of further
demonstrate that let's go back to our
app table view and I'm going to add some
markdown text so hello world with a
newline character at the end and if I
save that
now notice here it's printing out hello
world in the side of this element more
specifically if I want to do text
content or something like that it's
going to print out that text content of
hello world
cool so what are we doing or how are we
planning to pars this markdown language
and print out HTML one way we can do it
now again I don't know if this is the
best way is we can just use regex
so basically we declare some rules we
declare what we need to replace those
strings that we find width and then we
run it once over our element
so the kind of show you a very basic
example let's try to process this one
with the four hash symbols alright I'll
just make it six hash symbols for now
so make it six save that so inside of
our buying component what we want to do
is we want to get the current text so L
dot text content and we want to build up
some HTML so hTML is a variable equal to
an empty string for now and we want to
kind of replace
text with some regex expression so I'm
going to say hTML is equal to text out
replace give it a regex expression and
then also give it some string
you
and then I'll explain this
and then after we have this HTML where
we've replaced our regex with Dom
elements we can just say Elva inner HTML
equals the HTML in fact let's just do
let HTML here and we just get rid of
that middleman
okay so for those of you who aren't that
familiar with regex let's just go ahead
and move on to this red X tester online
thing where we can play around with it
to kind of understand what we're doing
so if we have some test string that
looks like this fact I have too many
hash symbols in it so let me go back and
remove that
well we have some test string that looks
like this how do we grab any string that
starts with six hash symbols and then
replace it with something else well
first of all we need to write regex
which is going to find six hash symbols
and then that regex expression is going
to be followed by a optional space
then what we want to do is grab and
group everything that's after that that
pretty much we can use a character class
here and say everything that's not a new
line and then group that so we can grab
it and then followed by a new line and
that is going to be our regex
mmm so again notice here we have six
hashes of space we have any character
that's not the newline one or more which
is this we're grouping it so that we can
actually extract it in our replace
method and then finally we end with a
newline so if I were to take this and
just plop it down into our regex here
and save it going back to our preview er
notice that this is now replaced
was kind of the demonstrate we found the
correct regex here and we replaced it
but we want to take that group and wrap
it in an h6 right so instead we can do
h6
and then inside these Dom elements or
this at XML we could just do money sign
one to grab the first grouping which is
here so now when I say this
notice that HelloWorld is printed out
and in h6
tag so if I were to inspect this notice
that h6 is here inside HTML and we are
currently processing our first markdown
rule
cool so now at this point
need to declare a bunch of different
rules to be able to process all the
different regex or markdown rules right
so here I'm gonna say constant rolls is
equal to an array of arrays and that
first entry in the array is going to be
our reg X I take this boom and our
second entry is going to be what we're
replacing it with so take this and boom
let's try get rid of those extra things
and what we can do is just loop over all
of our rules and do the same logic here
on line 9 so I'm going to say rules dot
for each
and roll template
this is just a raid deconstructing and
then I could just go ahead in basically
run the same command but instead of
hard-coding these I'm going to say role
templates
cool so if I say this you should get the
same outcome
but now we've abstracted our rules in
such a way that we can simply just add
some more so if we were to go back and
go ahead and try to add like a role for
just one hash symbol notice that this
reg X is not being fixed because we have
an editor roll forward so if I go here
and just add one hash this is going to
be h1 with h1
hmm notice that that it's gonna be an h1
now so before we type out all the
different rules which is just basically
knowing how they do regex and I'm not
going to probably gonna go over all
these since some of them get a little
bit complicated one thing I'll notice is
that as you type different stuff
it's not updating in the preview and
that is because this is only calling
once when the directive binds and the
Dom element is put into the page so it's
never actually going to re-render this
stuff
so to kind of fix that I don't know if
this is a proper solution I'm sure
there's a way to make our directive a
little bit more complicated to do this
dynamically such as like watching port
in fact this is maybe why you may want
to use a prop instead I mean a component
instead but I'm not sure if you can
access the Dom from a component but
anyway what we can do is we want to just
basically re render this Dom element
anytime markdown changes right so one
thing we could do is just bind key to
this
and I think we could just give it
markdown so basically anytime markdown
changes this is going to re-render our
preview over here if I save this
as I type different stuff
notice that it's rerender on the right
at this point we can just go ahead and
copy and make those other rules so H
five four three two
then over here we can save 5 4 3 2 1
save this
verify that this is working one two
three or five
a b c e okay
well so we have basically a preview are
good to go
the last step is just gonna be updating
all these roles to UM support all the
different markdown I don't know if I
want to go through all the different
rules because honestly it's just write
checks so you may want to just take a
tutorial on regex but it's basically
going to be the very very similar logic
so I'll do maybe like one or two so one
regex you should be able to do is bold
so what we could do here is we're gonna
do find me a string which has stars
let me just get rid of all this and try
again so find me a string that has some
stars
inside the center of those we want any
text that is not a star
so slash star
in fact I think I need to escape the
stars and you one or more so I think
this should work I save this and make
sure I change this to a bold tag instead
now and of course make sure you have the
grouping there oh let me add that
grouping
you
if I were the type stars are bold boom
ok bulbs working now and I could easily
just do that with like italics right so
I'll just go and do just a single slash
is going to be italics
and save that file
we have bold we have italics
awesome
that'd be nice to have is we want to
make sure every newline character wrap
something in a paragraph so if I just go
back here and say wrap my content or my
group in a paragraph if it is sandwiched
between a newline character
so I'm going to say give me the
parentheses give me every character that
is not a newline character like so
give me one or more of those and then
also give me the it has to end with the
newline character
and let's see that this works as indeed
okay so basically it's going to grab
the ends with the new line is gonna put
on a new paragraph after it does all
this stuff I don't know if this is the
proper way to do it it's just one one
solution so we could go through and
basically do all the different styles
but what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna I'm
just gonna copy and paste the remaining
roles in and we should just be able to
kind of wrap up this tutorial cuz I
don't wanna spend too much time doing
regex
in this tutorial
hmm so now at this point we should have
access to all those different the mark
10 that we saw before so as an example
we can do
the link
you
so now we have links which is this one
down here like 20 images like we saw
before we could do lists like we saw
before
[Music]
awesome so that basically wraps up our
markdown preview tutorial again if you
have a better suggestion as to how I
could be making this directive I know
you can probably get super complicated
using javascript and like changing Dom
elements and whatnot but I wanted to
keep it kind of simple as I could just
using regex and simple binding method
again like using this holing key maybe
that's not the best approach to kind of
rerender in this be sure to subscribe
and also I'll put my Twitter link below
which is also where I kind of give out
updates and then the github repo is also
going to be in the description below
alright thank you so much for watching